Tonight, the NFL
is sticking with Elon Musk.
The league condemning
hate speech
in a statement today
but says it won't stop advertising on X
after Musk
agreed with a message
that accused Jewish communities
of hatred against whites.
This is major companies
like IBM, Apple,
Disney and Warner Brothers.
Discovery, which owns CNN,
all pulled ads from X
one client, though,
that has not stopped working.
Hand in hand with Elon Musk
is one of his most important.
The US government.
Christine Fisher is OUTFRONT
And the Pentagon is getting in deeper
with Elon
Musk Falcon heavy going to Space Force
giving Musk's
private space company SpaceX
X, a contract for up to $1.2 billion
to send secretive spy
satellites into space.
But that's not all.
The Pentagon is also investing up
to $70 million in Star Shield,
a more secure version of SpaceX's massive
constellation of StarLink satellites,
which are vital to the Ukraine
military's success
against Russia on the battlefield.
I can confirm that we
do contract for StarLink for services
in support of Ukraine
with the ultimate objective
to be ensuring
that Ukraine
has the satellite
communication infrastructure
that it needs.
And Nasser couldn't
send another astronaut to the moon
without Elon Musk's company
Musk Starship is the most powerful rocket
ever built,
and it launched on its second test
flight on Saturday.
Nasser will spend about Four-dollar year
dollars on it
because it will be the lunar lander
of the space agency's
flagship Artemis program.
It's likely America's
only chance to beat China to the moon
in this second space race.
Go, dragon,
go for NASA's ultra reliant on Space X
to launch astronauts
to the International Space Station.
For now,
no other launch provider
other than the Russian government
can do it.
SpaceX X is on tap
because they have done the best.
Doug Loverro
is one of the few people
who's been a top official
at the two government agencies
most dependent on Elon Musk's companies.
And he describes
Nasser as being much
more reliant on SpaceX X
than the Pentagon.
SpaceX
is predominant right now,
but they're by no means the monopoly
that we all depend upon.
While the U.S.
does have other partners,
SpaceX X
has been dependable
in a dangerous business,
which could explain why they continue
to work with Musk.
The White House has condemned
for spreading antisemitic messages.
Last year,
the United States conducted
78 successful launches and SpaceX X
was responsible for 61 of them.
That's the same number of launches
as the Chinese government.
And nearly eight times
the amount of Space X's closest U.S.
competitor.
The United Launch Alliance,
a joint venture
between Boeing and Lockheed Martin.
This year, SpaceX has already surpassed
that record
with 85 orbital launches and counting.
For now and for the near future.
The U.S.
government's access to space
is overwhelmingly tied to SpaceX. X.
And a White House
spokesman said Monday
that he's, quote,
not aware of any efforts to change that.
There's innovation out there
in the private sector
that we'd be foolish to to
to walk away from.
I'm not aware of any specific efforts
to address
to to address our
concerns over his rhetoric.
But that doesn't mean that we accept
or or agree with or condone in any way
that antisemitic rhetoric that he pushed
Now, CNN has reached out to SpaceX.
So far, no comment.
As for NASA, it has had plans in place
for years to try to reduce its dependency
on one company.
You have Boeing's Starliner spacecraft
designed to ferry astronauts
to the space station next year.
Blue Origin
has a lunar lander
alternative for the Artemis program.
But, Erin,
the problem
is that
neither of those options are ready yet
Erin. All right.
Christine, thank you very much.
And Harry Enten joins me
now to go beyond the numbers.
I mean, it's amazing what Kristen's
reporting, right?
The amount of money that the U.S.
government spends.
But when you look at IBM,
Apple, Disney, Warner
Brothers, Discovery,
all these people pulling ads.
Does this hurt X's bottom line?
Absolutely. Does, Aaron.
I mean, if you look at the ad revenue,
they pulled it in 20, 22.
You compare it to
what's projected in 20, 23.
It's drop in half.
Drop in half.
Now, they're still making you
know, nearly $2 billion in ad revenue,
but it's significantly less
than the $4.1 billion
that they made last year.
I mean, 50% job is horrible.
It's a horrible, horrible performance.
Let's just call it out.
Yeah.
You note,
you know, stocks better than I do.
That is not a good performance.
No, it's it's it's horrible.
It's it's
unacceptable from
if you are a publicly traded company,
obviously this isn't so But let's.
Who is using X right now?
I mean, what is
so you talk about advertisers coming off.
Has there been a shift
since Elon Musk took over?
And there's been a lot more talk
about the whole
the whole platform shifting more, right?
Absolutely.
If you look at the people
who are regularly
getting their news on Twitter,
you look back in 2022
according to the Pew Research Center
it was two to one Democratic.
You look now
Democrats have been leaving the platform.
Republicans have been
joining the platform.
Now, it's
basically even in terms
of the percentage of Democrats
and Republicans
who are regular users
for Twitter getting their news.
But here's the thing I'll point out,
which is that fewer
people are regularly getting their news
on Twitter right now.
If you compare where we are now
to compared to where we are.
You want to say something?
Yeah.
No, I just I'm jumping
because we only have a few seconds left.
I want to make one point, by the way.
I'm sure Elon Musk would
say, look, half Democrat,
half Republican, that's a win.
That's why I did this.
Has it hurt his bottom line?
No, it hasn't hurt his bottom line
because that's not
where he makes most of his money.
An X or Twitter.
He makes most of his money,
for instance, in Tesla right.
So what we see is that his bottom line,
the amount of money that he has,
he's making he now
his net worth is more than $200 billion.
That is up from $170 billion last year.
So he'll look at this
and say, I'm richer.
Half Democrat, half Republican.
And he sees it possibly as a win.
All right. Thank you very much, Harry.